or during individual wouldn't know what
democracy it what your budget is they
just think it's something which gives
them their due rights are they wrong to
ask for their rights
there's blatant corruption in the
country the economic status of the
country is deteriorating day after day
and you really can't expect people to
sit back and just watch this whole thing
blow over
I honestly believe this is a step in the
right direction because you think you're
instilling a sense of ownership within a
person himself that's this is my country
I have a certain demise I have certain
rights in this country and the ruling
political party or the current executive
cannot go around pushing me around I
have an opinion of my own I have a voice
of my own and I will make it heard that
is what a truly democratic society can
get little subscribe on YouTube follow
us on Twitter and like us on Facebook